okay let's continue our coverage of
Public Health of infectious disease and
the incompetence of this administration
in the context of the now possible
corona virus pandemic headlines have
been floating around that Donald Trump
fired the u.s. pandemic response team
this sounds crazy why would any
president fire the pandemic response
team is this really true and the answer
is yes it is it is true the Trump
administration fired the u.s. pandemic
response team in 2018 to cut costs this
started circulating after Judd Legum who
runs the popular information newsletter
tweeted quote with the coronavirus
killing thousands and threatening to
tank the global economy I feel like more
people should be talking about the fact
that Trump fired the entire pandemic
response team two years ago and then
didn't replace them Trump also cut
funding for the CDC forcing the CDC to
cancel its efforts to help countries
prevent infectious disease threats from
becoming epidemics in 39 of 49 countries
in 2018 among the countries abandoned
China and Judd goes on to say this isn't
about this isn't just about
accountability it's about drawing
attention to these structural problems
in the US response effort before things
get worse we are seeing this front and
center here in the United States we are
seeing front and center how stuff that
is just politics very quickly becomes
life-and-death and much more than mere
political posturing and positioning
White House officials tasked with
directing national responses to
pandemics were fired in the spring of
2018 that's true and as Snopes points
out Rear Admiral Timothy Zimmer abruptly
departed from his post leading the
global health security team on the
National Security Council in May 2018
amid a reorganization of the council by
then National Security Advisor John
Bolton
tzemre steam was disband
Tom Bossert who is the Washington Post
reported had called for a comprehensive
bio defense strategy against pandemics
and biological attacks had been fired
one month prior if it weren't tragic
life and death it would be
indistinguishable from some kind of
weird comedy or satirical skit but it's
all real it's true that the Trump
administration cut the executive branch
team responsible for coordinating
responses to pandemics did he cut CDC
funding yes he did 20-18 reports say
that funding for the CDC's global
disease outbreak prevention efforts were
cut by 80% which includes the CDC's
effort in China the central point the
focus of coronavirus today when we've
been sounding the alarm for three years
now saying this man is a danger to the
country that was not a metaphor that was
not hyperbolic this was simply the sober
assessment of the situation the way to
observe this administration is to try to
ignore the propaganda videos and look
only at what they do
right the big videos of Trump looking
tough and heroic in China or India
rather or wherever it is that he's
traveling to don't look at how they
present themselves watch what they do
and you will very quickly understand the
incompetent reality of what is taking
place here we had enough to worry about
economically before coronavirus we had
enough to worry about socially the
fabric of politics and discourse in the
United States geopolitically we had more
than enough to worry about with Donald
Trump we had more than enough to worry
about with Donald Trump without a
growing outbreak of coronavirus which
medical experts have said Trump's
response to so far has been and I quote
incoherent now we also have that to
worry about as well and we have morons
running the response when I say we'll be
lucky to get out of this alive I that's
literally the case for millions and
millions of
people if this continues to grow and we
need competent people this isn't about
do we build a wall or not okay this is
not about frump claiming that he's
building the wall when he's not we are
talking about a life-and-death situation
potentially for millions of people and
we have arguably the least competent
people in charge absolutely concerning I
you know you all know that from that
we've been reporting on coronavirus for
months and from the beginning I said I
am NOT going to become more alarmist
about this than the facts actually
suggest and early on when you're
starting to see very alarmist reporting
in some places we were sober in our
assessment of what was going on
contextualizing coronavirus looking at
SARS looking at influenza so on and so
forth we are seeing growing numbers that
are cause for more concern but the real
red alert now is the incompetence of the
people we have in charge and the fact
that a lot of the competent people have
been fired let me know where your head's
at so to speak on coronavirus we'll take
a quick break and be back with much more
right after this